[Musique]
bonjour alors voilà il ya quelques
années j'ai fait un cauchemar et j'ai
l'impression que ce cauchemar devient
prémonitoire alors attention je voudrais
avant tout préciser que je ne suis pas
le petit petit petit fils de jeanne
d'arc lit celui de noé
mais c'est vrai que après ce cauchemar
j'ai ressenti comme une mission
alors je vais pas dire j'ai entendu des
voix mais même si on peut s'arrêter de
30 secondes sur jeanne d'arc ou non et
c'est vrai que voilà il y en a qui vont
dire qu'ils ont vraiment entendu des
voix et est la voix de dieu ou d'autres
ils ont été tout simplement la fij et
d'une mission ils ont senti qu'ils
avaient besoin de de faire ce qu'ils ont
fait voilà ce que ce café jeanne d'arc
ou noël mais voilà moi j'ai ressenti que
voilà j'ai ressenti comme une mission
que je devais que je devais faire
je vais je vais aller plus dans le
détail tout à l'heure mais le plus gros
de la mission ce serait de rencontrer le
président de la république le ministre
mise de la justice mises de l'intérieur
parce que j'ai vraiment des choses à
dire je pense avoir une solution une
solution pour tous les problèmes de
délinquance et tout ça mais avant de
rentrer vraiment dans le détail voilà il
faut vraiment revenir quelques années en
arrière
vraiment au moment de mon enfance je me
présente je suis david desclos je viens
de normandie
un quartier qui s'appelle la pierre
heuzé et aussi j'ai fait partie d'un
gang qui s'appelle qui s'appelait le 43
rue montcalm la cité déchets thann je
dois raconter un petit bout de mon
enfance même si je ne veux pas chercher
des excuses à la suite de ce que vous
entendre mais voilà c'est vrai que
c'était un quartier très pauvre très
très chaud et voilà papa dans l'alcool
une maman qui essayait de faire ce
qu'elles pouvaient j'avais mon petit
frère ma soeur on voit là on était
vraiment très très pauvre et il fallait
trouver des solutions pour manger pour
s'habiller et ses solutions les plus
grands du quartier nous l'ont montré
ils nous ont montré une direction la
direction du centre commercial
ils nous ont montré comment il fallait
faire pour manger comment fallait faire
pour s'habiller
c'était aussi dès l'école primaire et
surtout au collège la mode des baskets
blanches
voilà des bien habillé les 501 surtout
au collège primaire un peu moins aux
primaires c'était plus pour ça pour
manger mais arrivé au collège voilà il y
avait toute cette mode et tout est celui
qui avait pas la panoplie jean 501
baskets blanches fly jaquette c'était
bouffon c'est malheureux à dire mais
c'était comme ça dans le car dans les
quartiers c'est comme ça donc on nous
initie très vite à vendre du shit on
nous montre je les dis ah comment voler
à l'étalagé et je ne m'expliquerai pas
pourquoi comment pourquoi mais je me
suis retrouvé parmi les meilleurs
meilleur voleur à l'étalagé
je rentrais dans les magasins peut-être
dû à ma petite tête blonde aux yeux
bleus
j'étais peut-être un peu moins regardée
que mes potes qui étaient en majeure
partie des noirs et des arabes
et très vite je me suis aussi lancé dans
le volant filouterie après est
spécialisé dans le vol est à l'âge ses
voiles en filou triste est rentré dans
les moyennes surfaces dans les mêmes
dans l'est dans les petites dans les
petits commerces essayer de prendre la
caisse sans arme et sans violence parce
que tout jeune j'ai vraiment ressenti ça
je n'étais pas un violent je voulais pas
faire de mal je voulais pas braquer et
est donc voilà je suis rentré très vite
dans c'est de plus en plus dans cette
délinquance j'ai monté les échelons
voilà l'état l'âge volant filouterie et
très vite les cambriolages de nuit même
deux jours parce que il y avait des
cambriolages embrayage la journée entre
midi et deux quand les commerces étaient
fermés ben nous on est cambriolé la nuit
on s'est attaqué au commerce la nuit et
puis de plus en plus j'ai ressenti qu'il
fallait pas sa taille et s'attaquer aux
particuliers aux gens qui avaient monté
un commerce qui avaient travaillé dur
pour avoir leur commerce
on a même cambriolé des maisons et j'ai
ressenti que c'était pas bien je me
souviens me met me retrouver dans une
maison en train de fouiller cette maison
j'avais l'impression de violer
l'intimité des gens je n'étais pas à
l'aise mais j'étais quand même
j'étais devenu anarchiste j'étais devenu
j'avais la rage contre la société pour
moi c'est la société qui avait mis mon
père dans l'alcool c'était la société
qui était responsable de 2 to de tous
nos maux de tous de tout ce qu'on était
en train de faire qui nous avait rendus
comme ça
et donc j'avais vraiment cette haine
contre la société plus je monte les
échelons dans la délinquance et dans le
banditisme et plus j'avais cette rage et
que j'étais persuadé qu' il n'y a que
comme ça que je pouvais m'en sortir que
je pouvais réussir dans la vie
et donc je me suis spécialisé dans la
neutralisation des systèmes d'alarmé
avec mes amis on a décidé de s'attaquer
qu'aux banques la nuit sans armes sans
violence on rentrait dans les banques on
neutralise l alarme ont découpé les
coffres forts
voilà on ça devenait comme notre métier
le la journée ont maîtrisé aussi le deal
de shit
donc on pouvait pas on pouvait pas
monter plus haut dans la plus haut ça
aurait été braquée s'arrêter voilà on
gardait encore ses limites c'est à dire
de ne pas braquer ne pas faire trop pas
faire trop de mal aux gens quand je dis
pas faire trop de mal aux gens parce que
je suis conscient aujourd'hui que
quelqu'un qui se fait qu'en brûlé mais
voilà il le vit comme un viol gelé je
l'expliquais tout de suite mais voilà on
se disait on s'attaque aux banques on
s'attaque au système donc hélas c est l
escalade l'escaladent je grandisse et
j'ai fait des séjours des allers retours
en prison
beaucoup beaucoup de deux mois de prison
deux ans de prison entourant plusieurs
peines
j'étais multirécidiviste classe est
irrécupérable jusqu'aux plus gros plus
gros casse avec mes amis on a décidé de
s'attaquer au siège social de la société
générale on a creusé un tunnel pendant
quatre mois dans les égouts jusqu'à
jusqu'au siège social de la société
générale de la salle des coffres et pour
une petite erreur de notre part on s'est
fait attraper sur cinq on s'est fait
attraper k2 les hôtes ont réussi à s'en
aller est arrivé en garde à vue on m'a
comparé spaggiari je voulais dit je t'ai
connu comme le loup blanc j'étais classé
irrécupérable et là je savais qu'il
fallait que je m'évade et à l'euro
pendant un transfert là où les flics
commencer les policiers commençaient à
me à délirer un peu sur moi me comparer
à l'émule de spaggiari celui qui avec
envoyé une la société générale dans les
années soixante dix et qui lui aussi
s'était évadé donc on était dans la
voiture pendant ce transfert il n'hésita
plus qu'à faire comme spaggiari dit il a
mis quatre mois à s'évader
moi j'étais déjà en train de préparer
mon évasion et cinq minutes plus tard
j'étais évadés je me suis évadé et là je
les ai laissé sur le cul et je suis
parti en cavale donc de cavale cavale un
ans de cavale j'ai retrouvé ma femme
et pendant cette cabale j'ai c'est là
que j'ai eu les premiers déclic je me
suis rendu compte de mon état j'étais
dans le sud de la france j'étais hébergé
par des gens qui travaillaient c'était
voilà c'était nouveau pour moi de sortir
du quartier sortir de mon gang et là je
voyais ces gens qui travaillent est qui
et qui partait le matin leurs enfants
allaient à l'école il allait au travail
je me retrouvais dans leur maison et je
me disais mais c'est sa portée la
sécurité moi j'avais cette épée damoclès
je savais que comme deux et deux font
quatre j'allais me retrouver en prison
et pendant cette cavale je comprenais je
prenais conscience de ceux de la force
de la liberté d'être libre de ne pas
donner sa vie à la justice est donc là
j'avais ces premier déclic
donc c'est pour ça je dis je dis déclic
mais c'est comme comme si je me faisait
comprendre des choses est que ces choses
il fallait que j'aille les expliquer aux
autres qu'il est qu'ils n'avaient pas
encore compris pour ça que j'ai parlé de
jeanne d'arc tout à l'heure de noé tout
ça c'est c'était le début de ces
ressenti qui m'ont fait aller vers cette
mission pour raccourcir donc voilà je me
suis rendu j'ai fait cinq ans de prison
en prison j'ai commencé à raconter tout
dans les promenades devant les jeunes et
je voyais que les jeunes m'écouter que
j'étais comme un un exemple pour eux et
il fallait que je trouve une façon de
leur parler sans être moralisateur sans
être pas ce n'est pas parce que je
voulais trouver une façon de leur parler
comme moi j'aurais aimé qu'on me parle à
l'époque et là je voyais je jeu j'ai
trouvé la seule façon qui m'est venue
c'est de leur raconter toutes mes
histoires avec beaucoup d'humour et de
dérision jamais j'adorais rigoler je le
raconter comment je me suis évadé
rien que racontait mon évasion il était
mort de rire parce que les policiers ont
fait une grosse boulette ce jour là donc
et pendant ma cavale chaque chaque étape
de ma cavale il m'est arrivé des choses
marrantes donc je les raconte et les
jeunes rigoler rigoler je veux raconter
comment ont dévalisé les coffres forts
comme on commet ont cambriolé les
banques et rigoler et ses essais au
moment où je les avais acquis que
j'avais et qu'ils étaient avec moi il
était en plein on peut en plein en plein
délire environ rigoler c'est là que je
me disais qu'il faut apporter les
messages et subtilement intelligemment
jeu j'envoyais mes messages c'est à dire
que
derrière toute cette rigolade il y avait
des années de prison derrière cette
rigolade y en avait qui y était mort
il y en avait il y avait des morts des
des victimes il y avait les victimes de
cambriolages les gens qui rentrent du
travail ou qui rentrent de vacances et
qui voyaient leur maison cambriolée et
qui qui mettent des années avant de se
remettre d'un cambriolage parce qu'ils
le vivent comme un viol un camp bref ça
dure cinq minutes le cambrioler le
cambrioleur il pense pas faire autant de
mal il se dit bon on est là pour prendre
du matériel et partir mais quand
quelqu'un ronde et qui voit sa maison
cambriolée qui voit qu'il est victime de
ce viol il dort plus pareil dans une
maison cambriolée y en a qui déménage
après un cambriolage
il y en a qui ont une bague qui
développent des maladies le moindre
bruit la nuit on sursaute
donc c'était leur expliquer ça donc du
rire on passait à la compréhension
il comprenait les messages et la
j'allais encore plus loin dans mes
messages je leur expliquais je leur
disais regarder le culot l'intelligence
le talent qu'on a pour pour faire tout
ce qu'on fait s'évader de cambrioler une
banque mettre au point ce tous ces
cambriolages cc c'est énorme
et si on met ce culot cette intelligence
et ce talent dans l'honnêteté
on peut tout déchirer et là je sentais
que j'étais écouter jeu que j'ai je
sentais que la magie opérer et donc je
continue encore encore plus loin je leur
disais je leur disais moi le plus gros
des déclics que j'ai eu c'est en plein
tribunal quand quand je voyais les juges
les procureurs les avocats la presse
tout le monde et que moi j'étais
condamné à sept ans ferme et que moi
j'allais en prison et que il rentrer
chez eux
je lui avais donné ma vie à ce système
et je leur expliquais que on ne doit pas
donner même pas 30 secondes de notre vie
à ce système même pas 30 secondes de
garde à vue ou deux il faut faire comme
comme ceux qui ont peur d'attraper des
maladies
il faut faire attention à sa santé mais
autant à sa liberté pour réussir sa vie
et là j'avais les mots et il me il
venait me voir et me disent et david tu
nous a fait rire mais tu nous a fait
comprendre des choses et là je me suis
dit il faut pas le faire que dans les
prisons il faut pas attendre que ces
jeunes se retrouvent en prison pour leur
expliquer tout ça et c'est là que j'ai
décidé d'écrire mon spectacle avec
beaucoup d'humour de dérision gelé
les nommés écroulé de rire et là je suis
arrivé dehors j'ai été faire les scènes
ouvertes
même pendant ma deuxième évasion je le
faisais en cavale tellement tellement je
sens en moi cette mission je recherché
par toutes les polices je monte sur
scène je le faisais quand même je
m'appelais peint lui l'envers de lupin
les janvier la suite la suite si je peux
pas je suis en cavale il était mort de
rire mais c'était vrai et je voyais que
la magie opérer les gens que je croisais
ou ou par l'acide quand j'étais plus en
cavale et venait me voir mais c'est
génial ce que tu dis tu dois le faire
dans les écoles dans l'est dans les
lycées dans les protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse et donc moi je n'osais pas
dire qu' il fallait que je rencontre le
président le ministre de l'intérieur le
ministre de la justice pour qui pour
qu'ils comprennent que c'est ensemble
qu'on doit travailler tout ça qu'on doit
essayer de faire en sorte que de créer
des commissions de la dernière chance
parce que je je sens que le peuple est
de plus en plus à bout contre la
délinquance il pense que que ce il faut
il faut faire des lois pour les leur
remettre dès que des peines planchers
des peines de pour dect en récidive pour
le moindre vol il faut le remettre des
30 ans des 40 ans de prison
je leur dis non laissez moi laissez nous
créer les commissions de la dernière
chance et dans ces commissions mettre
des victimes à porter la justice
restaurative que les victimes montre aux
jeunes ce que c'est qu'être une victime
dans cette commission m des anciens
délinquants qui qui ont la crédibilité
qui vont être écouté par ses jeunes des
éducateurs des juges expérimentés voit
une commission et qu'on fasse cette
commission cette tournée de la dernière
chance dans les prisons dans les
quartiers dans les écoles dans tout
essayer d'en sauver le maximum
j'essaye de le crier il faut le faire
parce que ce que nous on a déjà réussi à
faire dans notre humble niveau
à notre humble niveau avec stomy bugzy
véronique gaymard le théâtre du gymnase
toute l'équipe qui est autour de moi on
l'a fait dans des écoles dans des
collèges dans des lycées dans des
prisons d une protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse
on a des retours magnifique autant par
les éducateurs que par les jeunes
on sent qu'on est en train de sauver
beaucoup mais c'est tous ensemble on a
besoin justement que ça monte encore
plus haut pour qu'on le fasse à grosse à
grande échelle qu'on montre l'exemple
qu'on montre que ce n'est pas foutu
qu'on ait aucun jeune n'est pas
irrécupérable
donc je me suis dit il ya qu' il n'y a
que en dévoilant ce secret qui est en
moi
puis c'est des années que que je serais
peut-être écouté lancer ce grand message
assez à ces politiciens à tout le monde
leur dire que c'est ensemble qu'on doit
essayer de sauver tous ces jeunes alors
je ne suis pas jeanne d'arc je ne suis
pas nos et je suis juste david desclos
et j'ai ce message de dire que je suis
sûr que ce n'est pas foutu et que on
peut ensemble faire quelque chose de
bien et fort et on peut en sauver
et si on peut en sauver même si ce n'est
que 10 15% 20%
eh ben c'est déjà fort et il faut le
faire mettre des années de prison à des
jeunes qui se retrouvent qui peuvent en
mourir
c'est très triste c'est très malheureux
autant pour les jeunes que pour les
victimes
et donc voilà je le dis ma phrase aide
toi et le ciel t'aidera
je suis david desclos et merci de
m'avoir écouté
[Musique]